we heard from one of our viewers who
hasn't gotten a trim since before the
pandemic
and we wanted to come to her rescue
check
this out hi
i'm jen from long island new york singa
mama who
is in desperate need of a haircut
look at this still long and uneven in
the back
split ends up to my ears and i haven't
even gotten a trim since before the
pandemic
my name is randy and jen is my daughter
she's been a school psychologist for
over 20 years
i took a break from my job when covet
hit
to be able to fully support my kids and
i
decided to make a career move and i
started a business
helping moms because of that she's just
been very very very busy
and hasn't had a chance to take care of
herself how can i tell moms to take care
of themselves when i'm not even taking
care of myself
so today i'm hoping we can get jan a
haircut that she truly deserves
and that would boost the spirits drew
can you help me with this hair i really
need a cut
oh jen please
by the way you are so pretty
thank you it's true that just happened
oh my gosh okay
well first of all your dad is here he's
someone who's very important to you
i love this he's gonna come out at the
end this is a whole family thing
all the feels now here's what i'm really
excited about as well other than your
dad of course
which is we have someone here in the
studio
i mean i can't believe he's here okay
his
celebrity clients include uh jennifer
lopez
kim kardashian ariana grande
yeah that's right the most incredible
hairdresser
is here ladies and gentlemen it's chris
appleton
hey guys how you doing hey
hi chris drew i'm here i know and we
just got to do a segment recently and
then i thought
oh gosh if we could ever be together and
here we are dreams come true
dreams do come true see we put it out
there and here we are i don't know about
you but i'm ready for
a makeover jen you ready for my show i'm
so ready for a makeover
all right chris and jen we will be
checking in throughout the whole hour
and bringing your dad out at the end
celebrity hair stylist extraordinaire
chris appleton has been working on our
viewer jen's hair
all hour long because it's the first
appleton hour
and she hasn't gotten it cut in more
than a year and
jen are you ready for your dramatic
transformation
[Applause]
i'm like speechless which doesn't ever
happen but this is
i feel like i'm going to go from this
she is this is the old gym
wow
from back burner single mama to hot mama
yeah thank you drew
and chris
thank you so much incredible well we
didn't come here to
just to give her a trim i think jen was
the perfect
i guess example of sometimes we can all
get stuck in a rut a little bit we get
comfortable with what we know
um and you know jen literally said to me
chris i want you to tell me what you
would do if i could let you do anything
i want you to do that
the cut is actually really easy for her
to wash and leave so i think that was
really important because she is a mum
that she could wash and go but if she
didn't want to put a flattening iron
through um she could also do that too
so i think for me i just wanted to give
her something chic her hair is very
straight so i was gonna make it super
curly and make it do something it didn't
do just to look good on the show and
then she goes home and can't do it
you just said the key thing and i said
when we did this show like if we were
ever to do a makeover we have to make
sure it translates
into real life because people get these
big makeovers they get sent out in the
world
and then they're trying to reassemble it
so you really did that and it's
time to bring out your dad randy who has
been anxiously waiting backstage
randy are you there i am
what do you think i think it's amazing
it's beautiful
i didn't think you get more beautiful
it's beautiful it really is
odd mom is the one with the happy tears
but i
i'm feeling it today i really feel it oh
thank you jen can i ask you why it was
important to have your dad here today
gonna make me cry my dad has been my
rock my whole life
and um he's seen me through the roller
coasters the highs the lows and i'm just
i'm ready for a high i've given so much
with my kids and being a school
psychologist and i'm
i'm ready to to take care of me again
and my dad no better person for
me to have here
[Music]
i don't want to mess you up jen i have
to tell you a story i spoke to my
amazing therapist
yesterday and he said you know i really
don't like telling
women who work or who are moms or both
that they should carve out time for
themselves he said where do you find
that
time and i do think that through this
pandemic and through this new normal
and our world as women we've got to
redefine
what finding something for ourselves
looks like
what it's worded as and i'm ready to
kick start
something powerful that doesn't make
women feel like they cannot
meet the moment which in turn isn't
giving anything to yourself except for
feeling like
you're already failing again which is
ridiculous
so here drew thank you so having a
moment with your dad
having the brilliant chris appleton give
you a transformation that you can take
with you
knowing who has set you up for success
and who you want to make proud and take
care of
that to me is um really knowing who you
are
and then maybe we can sidebar and figure
out how to give back to ourselves
and um chris i love your brand color wow
too
um yeah i mean listen i'm an ambassador
for a while but i'm going to make sure
that you go home with this jen this is
the dream coat
this is what gives you that mirror-like
shine so you'll be able to keep up with
that really nice high shine because that
for me i think when you've got that
short little
bob and it has that high shine in that
swishy feel i think that's the selling
factor for me so
well make sure you leave with that as
well i want to try that like glass stuck
too that gives the wet look
all right jen randy chris appleton thank
you all so much for joining us today for
the bffs and those who
are kind enough to be watching at home i
hope you get to take
this good energy with you because
it is all about you have a wonderful day
[Music]